francamente de manera masiva
la democracia puede darnos de nuevo el
medio para cambiar de rumbo la tercera
vuelta comienza esta noche
a los 12 y 19 de junio tendrán lugar las
elecciones legislativas ustedes pueden
en este momento vencer al señor marco y
escoger un camino diferente los del 12 y
el 19 de junio
otro mundo es todavía posible si ustedes
eligen a una mayoría y digo bien a una
mayoría de diputados de la nueva unión
popular que debe ampliarse
el bloque popular
que se constituyó en torno a mi
candidatura a la elección presidencial
en este país ahora a partir de ahora es
el tercer estado que puede hacerlo
cambiar todo si se reúne si se agrupa y
se si se amplia el 12 y el 19 de junio
los invito a que me elijan primer
ministro y los llamo así en realidad a
darle vida a un nuevo futuro común para
nuestro pueblo
valor por favor acción determinación
rechazar siempre la fatalidad y la
resignación
viva francia viva la república